ragazzi sta per iniziare il finale di
the forest lo dividono in due puntate
perché un po lungo questa è la prima la
prossima uscita mercoledì prossimo il
finale di the forest and the forest è un
gioco che porto da quattro quasi cinque
anni sul mio canale tantissimo che porta
fuori non l'ho mai finito ho deciso di
riportarlo in live siamo arrivati al
finale e adesso vi di registro il video
così vi rimane proprio anche quindi
editato e montato del vero finale di le
forest parte 1 buona visione
buonanno buonanno bravo ciccio bonanno
dai fuoco alla cadiamo fuoco alla casa
buon anno a tutti amici popolo di
internet siano qua sono qua con tutte le
tutti i miei amici e non ne ho più in
realtà ci siete solo voi nella mia vita
abbiamo tom che a un respiratore in
bocca poi abbiamo pietro che ha
respirato in bocca c'è la motosega
abbiamo ciccio che ha un coltello e
respiratori in bocca
poi ci sono io che non ho l'ispiratore
perché l'ho lasciato dove c'è il teschio
si preannuncia una giornata fantastica
stiamo per finire the forest
perché se vi ricordate c'è una voragine
gigantesca che questa che state vedendo
in immagine al fondo di quella voragine
c'è una pozza grazie a tom per decorare
il mio discorso c'è una puzza dove se
noi ci andiamo dentro con le bombole che
loro hanno e io no adesso andiamo a
prenderla andiamo verso il finale di
default e non so se questa roba dura da
più di un episodio penso di sì perché
dobbiamo ancora recuperare la mia roba
ma stiamo per la prima volta sul mio
canale maledizione finire
siamo per finire the forest tutti noi
sono contente che ci siete tutti ragazzi
siete la mia famiglia abbiamo ci bene
per iniziare bene vi devo dire una cosa
la calabria in questa testa è una bomba
scappata aiuta
non si sa prendendo per il culo e una
bomba sul serio si dorme in quattro in
una tenda che non tiene neanche una
persona buongiorno ragazzi questa è la
voragine
non so se ve la ricordate nei vecchi
episodi di the forest e la mia roba
stalli in mezzo ok ci sono voli per
arrivare imposti da qua e muori quindi
non ci arrivi o devi fare un giro un
pelo strano dunque farlo senza
respiratore
io devo prendere l'ispiratore che sta lì
dove sono morto capito ho capito ma puoi
fare il prezzo tradiva e non a firminy
castelbasso respiratore prima stiamo
andando a prenderlo no la posta per
arrivare al finale al mio respiratore ci
possa arrivare senza benzina che serve è
dietro queste benzina che mi ci siamo
arrivati
ci siamo ragazzo per recuperare la mia
roba fermi tutti
eccolo eccomi ci sono le mie cose
sono quattro i vestiti aveva investito
bene adesso cosa c'è in mano dietro un
teschio cos'è alla mia arma
prego diamo ora che bella questa scia ti
piace piacere
andiamo andiamo andiamo anche un
elicottero schiantato non fate domande
la forza è quella lì in mezzo ce la
vedete
dobbiamo scendere piano tom ti ammazzi
si è fatto male se è un po volto noto a
dovevo scendere
mi sa che non avete capito il concetto
di piano prova perché esagerazione ma la
distanza non ci sono uscito va bè
ragazzi non si fa senza ciccio come a
posto se ho fatto niente ragazza posto
elvis è fatto niente per niente
e possibile che dietro non devi andare
pietro pietro piedi pieni di sale per
scendere rivali sono saliti marinara
madonna di dio dove andrò a salvare
quello di lacation box
aiuto io con la farà carico arriva al
posto dietro pietro adesso regalbox
dietro pietro dietro sale quasi lato
destro
questi qua non c'era bisogno di farli
fuori lega non c'è bisogna notare questa
thomas dov'è stato pista mori di pietro
sta aprendo le casse quell'uomo aprile
classe c gente lingua vinicola guarda
guarda se muori che lo meritino siamo
ritiro meriti qua qua di salire quali
qua questa andando avanti e spetta
pietro svetta che non evita recupera la
lav e ragazzi dobbiamo entrare lì dentro
è lì dentro ci sarà il finale i miei
amici non aspettano niente diamo
aspettiamo sott'acqua tutti valenza
raviolo e non lo so non vedo niente
perché stai facendo tu ti ho visto
girare velocissimo qualche pietra non è
proprio se non sarebbe arrivato in
questo punto nel messo il mio canale non
sono variati così lontano posso portarla
anche come fatto a morire tom dai perché
si è arrivati rispettate allora cosa
puoi fare
il fuoco si forse si aspetta un secondo
aspetto che mettono un secondo infatti
noli rete le foglie miti le polemiche ce
l'hai bravo effetto fa la forza
quanto tempo per arrivare eccolo è
arrivato il primo la lontra valere
azioniamo ci siamo tutti prego
costruiamo qua dentro e non sono mai
entrato qua in video sono emozionato
grazie amici miei gravare che sono bravi
se si impara della serie buoni prima tu
ed è esattamente quello che farò ma con
onore
aia che male fanno questi tshirt hano
ragazzo
ora che mi hanno fatto fuori vedere star
come madonna ci hanno aperto l'anno
dovete restarci tutti e due
vi assicuro che sia morto direi che è
morto occhi occhi occhio
ovvio che a un certo punto cade puntate
mila torch acqua ma il cielo la torcia
mi sa qual è vero sì si capisce davvero
si fa veramente una suite
ma cos'è una cassetta che accettano
scritto invasioni di mutanti vabbè ma
ora vedo l'inferno siete pronti questo è
il passo finale musicale pick up
questa non è musica etnica nella partita
inediti ma tu hai twitter dopotutto
ottimo che figata
ma chi aspetta tra poco c'è gente c'è
gente non ha paura di loro e io sì
quindi è un punto di merito che male
ovvio che si fanno il male incredibile
un andato a vogliono guardare altre cose
però la donna fanno marione è morto cc è
morto stai tranquillo oggi ventenne sono
stati fortissimi occhio c'è ancora uno
che mai vabbé vabbé quanto levano lemon
orme ramo volontà tantissimo ci siamo
lasciate che c'è ancora gente sicuro c'è
una pozza lilla a sinistra c'è gente non
fatevi vedere state ha detto abbiamo già
vista
ti conoscevo il tipo è scemo dobbiamo
arrivare alla fine possiamo anche
lasciare lasciare il finale tra quanti a
lasciare il finale
diamo il momento sia il momento eccolo
bravo ma dietro c'è nessuno dietro di un
bravo bravo madonna
c'è un tizio chiesto tizio ancora
qualcosa no e mi ha fatto fuori tutti
abbiamo il cavolo sta comodi sa cos'è il
gioco così quanto spetta la favola si
cela favor terra c'è una foto per terra
lo sla internet abbiamo la tessera per
aprire la porta ce l'abbiamo la tessera
te l'abbiamo del saharawi apri che
riguarda l'abbonamento della palestra
previa si è fregiato spettanza rai ha
fissato il co2
ok ok quella non è un ambientazione da
the forest che io sappia
potete mettere gli elettori sono un
sacco di rossi sta roba sia permessa
ecco non sono mai entrato e c'è un
trapano saliamo saleri qua nei condotti
tipo metalli ha mai portato a sta roba
che figo c'è una medicina equa ragazzi
medicine medicine prendi non fare
informazione
le ossa o rubato anche pietro ai rilievi
che figata
facciamoci le armature allora per esatto
un po matura con armatura la stoffa
paranormale mostri come ora seguite
tutti quanti me senza fare i pirla ecco
lo sapevo che ha fatto il pirla no ho
accesso al corridoio 7 o cos'è sta roba
c'è un trapano c'è una tipa che una tipa
megan scream le foto ma prende internet
ed agganciano le mail
abbiamo ancora sotto che è successo tu
sei pazzo io meno male che non sono
stato vicino a voi perché sono
previdente qua sopra è una specie di
mensa ma che figo e lo so ha prezzo ho
messo dei soldi nella mi ha dato una
lattina mette i soldi dentro i cosi che
vi da allegri snack
non sempre i soul che figata e quindi
ragazzi si conclude qui la prima parte
del finale di the forest ci sarà il
prossimo video che sarà l'ultimo quindi
il finale finale finale in finale molto
lungo ma fighissimo fighissimo ne varrà
la pena anche perché io ho già
registrato spero che vi sia piaciuto
come mi piace anche per il social che
come dono descrizione passate anche sul
canale dei ragazzi che vi lascio sempre
schizzare se non si da quelli scritti al
mio momento di scrivere e noi ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo da ragazzi esce
mercoledì il finale finale esce
mercoledì questo mercoledì
[Musica]